okay um
thank you so much uh there was a you
know
it was a rough start but better than
nothing
right um okay let's
officially start uh welcome to the ddps
seminar everyone before we introduce our
invited speaker today let's go over some
rules and logistics as usual
first of all please mute yourself during
the talk
unless you have questions if you have
questions you are welcome to mute
yourself and ask those questions
otherwise please use chat room to post
your questions so that we can address
them
in q and a session at the end second
today's ddps
seminar is open to external audiences
so no classified discussion is allowed
please watch out and finally the talk
today will be recorded and uploaded in
our
in our youtube channel that's about it
now let me introduce our speaker today
it is an honor to host professor david
who is a
professor in mainz paris tech
university and the head of the program
phd program
in mechanical engineering he has coined
the word
hyper reduction in reduced auto model
community which is
very crucial especially for non-linear
dynamical system model order reduction
and he also did seminal work in a
a priory modal reduction and
he was the head of the research team
involving 12
permanent researchers at mainz paris
tech from
2011 to 2015 his
current research focuses on model
reduction multiphysics modeling of
thermal mechanical processes and inverse
problems
okay today david will present model
order reduction assisted by deep
neural network so-called raw math
which is a great interest to us so
please enjoy and
expect a wonderful talk from david
now without further ado let me pass the
button to david
by asking one random questions today's
random question
is what's the smartest thing you've ever
done
in your life oh
it was the birth of my uh first uh
daughter yes yes of course
how many kids do you have uh three
oh i know and one door yeah i see
of course yeah i knew that was the
answer
okay it's all yours david okay
thank you young soul for your kind
invitation for this
seminar and it's great for you
yeah make sure share your screen yes
yeah so
do you see my presentation here
yeah but it's not full screen can you
make it now it's full screen
i i think yes okay so
i would like to talk about uh model
order reduction
assist by deep neural network
and extern romnet
so uh at the school of mines
we are working on digital images
on materials and we try to
make digital twins of these images
and obviously we need deep learning
for various interactions between images
and machine learning or between machine
learning
and finite element model i would like to
explain that
uh through this presentation
so i i'm going to talk about romnets
developed during the phd thesis of
thoma daniel and this
research was funded by saffron
so what are the motivation
why there is three interacting
discipline
in my logo there is three main factors
promoting the development of machine
learning for
engineering application in mechanics
first material imagine made huge
progresses
in terms of resolution but also
thanks to the development of x-ray
tomography
and x-ray tomographic and captures
the 3d morphology of various kind of
metals and composite materials
second such observations can be used to
feed numerical
modeling in digital twins but
also in various physical models
and today supercomputers
are available in order to
make huge simulation especially finite
element
simulation and on the top of that
machine learning especially for image
transformations
has become more efficient and robust
these last two decades and both for
supervised and self-supervised learning
tasks
and we all know that piton libraries are
freely available
so for all of that today it is
time for the interaction of these
disciplines
to develop engineering tasks assist
by deep learning
in aeronautics or in many
other industrial sectors here
engineers as have to design or exploit
complex systems where decisions
are supported by numerical models
this is term model based system
engineering
complex systems in fact are systems
that require model based engineering
these models have an informatic
representation
here on specialized
informatics platforms in these platforms
we find workflows that connect
cad to finite element solution
of partial differential equation
and when the simple numerical
models are available
one can run uncertainty quantification
for
robust optimization purpose
or for decision making the ground truth
here for uncertainty quantification
comes from
observational data
especially those related to
manufacturing processes
but uncertainty can also comes from
complex environment and
like in a multiphysic problem
so i would argue that data
in engineering is valuable
as much as it is in healthcare for
example
thanks to the experience of most people
in the audience
today we know that
storing data can save time if we use
machine learning
this opens new opportunities for more
uncertainty quantification
and robust optimization
such tasks are still very hard to
perform
on complex system
especially since the source of
uncertainty
are incr grazing with improvement
of imaging techniques for engineering
the role of image of images
in numerical modelling will certainly
grow
in the future here it is an example
of x-ray tomography of defects
in a welding joint
in image-based models images
are input parameter for
numerical models and these parameters
are denoted by mu they are physical
parameter
the parameter space or the ambient space
for
images is so huge then
dimensionality reduction makes sense
for both parameters like images
as well as simulation data
we obviously adopt the data driven
modeling approach
in practice during the design of complex
system or during the
exploitation the parameter space
is sampled many times
similarly to physics informed neural
networks
data drive and modeling for modern
reduction
aims to make the to make the best use
of existing data while exploiting the
information
of from classical mathematical model
in my point of view we can achieve this
kind of of learning by
transfer learning we
we will see that later in my talk
but in engineering science we seek for
interpretable models
and it is a very difficult topic in
machine learning
model-based engineering are
100 interpretable but
sometimes too deterministic
global interpretability in machine
learning describes the
overall features that mostly contributed
to the model's performance and
local interpretability works at the
online step
and represents the features that
contributed to a specific decision
for a specific input
we need both in engineering
let's talk now about the simulation data
so simulation data opera
produced by numerical solution of
partial differential equation
the solution is sorry the solution of
this partial differential equation is
denoted by u
and this solution is parameter dependent
because the partial differential
equation l
is parameter dependent it depending
is depending on mu
so the solution is both defined over a
spatial domain
denoted omega and over
parameter space p
here the matrix x
as is a storage matrix of
simulation data each time
we sample the parameter space we get
a new parameter mu i
and we put this mu i
in the row of the matrix x
here the idea behind data drive and
modeling
is that the row of x the rows of x
do not fill up the anterior
embedding space
the the data
are solution of the pde
and they are living on the latent space
i would say a true latin space
this is the green curve here
and it is sampled by blue points
each time we solve the
partial differential equation by using a
finite element model
the finite element model has a residual
r and it has a vector of degrees of
freedom q
each time we do a simulation a finite
element simulation
we fulfill this equation the residual
equal to zero and this define the true
equation of the true latin space
so in in fact we exactly know the
equation
of this latent space for a finite
element model
uh the the solution of this residual
equal to zero is very expensive it
is too long and we want to get a simpler
equation
for the latent space
for example one of the target
application
for romnet is the thermomechanical
simulation of a turbine blade
in this blade the temperature
field is a random variable
and it is an input variable for the
mechanical
problem in the mechanical problem
it's an elastoplastic problem uh
with the finite element method so we
have
finite element shape function and uh
nodal degrees of freedom q j
and in this kind of example
we have 15
millions of degrees of freedom
and the solution for 100
loading cycles takes 300 days
to get the plasticity inside the blade
so it's very complex simulation and we
would like to find
a reduced latent space for that kind of
simulation
so here we are using universal
approximation theorems of feed forward
neural networks to get
reduced equations for the latent space
we seek for data driven approximation
by using an approximate an approximation
space
v l as a subspace of the finite element
so rom nets are using projection based
model order reduction
why why not using metamodels
and regressions via supervised
learning as i said earlier
projection-based model order reduction
enables a kind of transfer learning
in that transfer learning the source
domain
is computational mechanics
the target domain is fast parametric
predictions
using machine learning
the knowledge encoded in pdes
is reused in a non-linear scheme
for projection-based model order
reduction
thus machine learning is only focused
on a few physical parameters
we don't have to rediscover all the
equations of physics
so we are focused on few on a few
physical parameters
but they are high highly dimensional
ones
like images for instance
so we are using machine learning we need
to train models
so uh for that we have a training step
also term offline step and
uh it it starts with a numerical
simulation
according to a sampling of the parameter
space
thanks to that we can arrange
the simulation results in the rows
of matrix x
usually x has much more colons than
rows so
we have a very big fidelity model
that no very well the knowledge in
physics
and we we run it to get
simulation data and it
ends by a reduced order model
that speed up simulation
dimensionality reductions reduction
belongs to
manifold learning methods
the radiospace is a data driven latent
space
that aims to retain some meaningful
properties
of the original data
ideally close to the interesting
dimension of the true latin space
note that manifold learning is fine for
data visually
visually visualization but here
we need equations for the reduced latent
space
the coordinates in these equations are
termed
reduce coordinate
so i would like a question i'd like to
ask a question
maybe you can reply to it by using the
chat but unfortunately i don't see the
chat
but uh what what is the linear latent
space
when all simulation data are aligned
what is the term for that in a linear
algebra
you sh certainly you know that usually
linear latent spaces
are well known for model order reduction
they are very interesting even if
the finite element model is non-linear
the linearity of the latent space and
the linearity of the finite element
equations
are two different things
so the answer to the equation is a
linear
latent space use these linear equations
so it is a vector subspace
of the finite element space
in the circle the reduced
coordinates on the reduced latin space
the reduced coordinate z
uh our vector of dimension
n very small compared to curly n
the number of degrees of freedom in the
finite element model
and thanks to that we have only
capital n equation so less equation to
solve
in order to find points onto the reduced
latent space
so with smaller
number equation it should be faster
so under complete auto encoders are
well-known
neural networks for dimensional
reduction of data
by using a latin variable z this is
the same z it performs
a non-linear dimensionality reduction
thanks to the decoder
these neural network are trained by
self-supervised machine learning
the output must be equal to the input
and the projection-based
reduced-order model using decoder of
auto-encoders
have been proposed by lee and carl berg
last year in this approach
a minimization of the finite element
residual
r is performed
by using the decoder of the
auto encoder
so here thanks to this
minimization problem we can find the
best
reduced coordinate and
we obtain thereafter the
the estimation of the degrees of freedom
q so we have less variables
but they are more non-linear because of
the
non-linearity of the decoder
if the activation function in the in the
encoder
and decoder are the linear function
and if we use two fully connected neural
network
we obtain a linear equation for
dimensionality reduction we obtain
linear dimensionality reduction
therefore x equals z
times the decoder v transpose
and the decoder v must be
obtained by solving an optimization
problem
the solution of this optimization
problem is given
thanks to the a cartoon theorem
and it is the svd uh
decomposition of matrix x that gave
that gives the best decoder v
so a linear encoder give
gives z equal to x time v
and the decoder x approximated by
z times v transpose
so uh in in modern order reduction
we use garlic in projection
and we need to introduce for that
the reduced approximation space
v rom that use the
the linear decoder v times
z transpose this is the transpose of the
previous
equation for linear algebra
and the garlic in projection reads
this equation it is the projection of
finite element residual onto
the subspace span by
the columns of v
so each time we have a parameter mu
we can find the z thanks to this
linear reduction approach
and we can see that the reduced
order model here is a supplement
to the decoder in order to
describe the point z onto
the latent space
so we we all we know most of us know
that
garlic in projection do not reduce
computational complexity sufficiently
because here the computation of the
residual
finite element residual scales with
the number of degrees of freedom
curly m so if we are using
a hyper reduction we can reduce this
complexity for instance we can use a
reduced integration domain for that
and therefore it is a selection of
a few residual finite element residual
in order to to obtain this
projection and
the purpose of rom net is to extend this
to non-linear model order reduction
a key idea for that is past dictionary
learning
spanish dictionary learning
allows residency in a dictionary
of empirical vector
and in in singular value decomposition
the loss function
is a two norm uh function
between the the
input and the output it is the two norm
of the
discrepancy between the the input and
the output
and uh this is fine for linear auto
encoder
but in sparse dictionary learning
the loss function contains l0
and l1 penalization terms
to enforce a sparse representation
of the latin variables
sparse dictionary learning
can be understood as a piecewise
linear latin space in some situation
let's consider the case
of k clusters of data
in x we have k cluster of data
and for each cluster
we can use the k svd
in order to get for each cluster
a proper reduced basis thanks to the
local svd in the cluster
so it is a kind of sparse dictionary
learning
and it is very interesting because it
gives
a piecewise linear radio space
and this enables
a hyper reduction it is very
straightforward
to apply a hyper reduction in that case
this has been proposed for instance by
using
the local dye
in addition sparse latin space are
desirable for interpretability
when the parameter space has a huge
dimension
it makes sense to define two different
categories
of data for example for the assessment
of defects
of artfulness of defects the category of
spherical defect
and the category of penetrate defect
can make sense so using clustering
strategy
can help for interpretability
and for this reason i i think is
this is my opinion that rom dictionaries
are very interesting for
interpretability
maybe they have a better
than auto encoders
so what is a regis order
model network
a romnet is a fit forward artificial
neural network
that ends with a reduced order model
via a projection based model reduction
it is designed mostly
for image image type
parameter as input parameter
for the nonlinear modal or order
reduction
and it aims to perform
an approximation of the latent space
by using a piecewise linear radius space
so we need to train cluster
to train cluster of simulation data
prior
the construction of local radius bases
per cluster and
this clustering procedure unable
to adopt a goal-oriented metric
for that clustering
the goal-oriented metric is the grassman
distance between
vector subspace this grassman distance
further measures the angles
between two reduce basis
here we replace
simulation data in the finite element
ambient space
by radius basis each point
is now an ideal radius basis
each simulation is transformed
thanks to the svd into
a reduced basis for edl radius basis
and this edl reduce basis
is the best reduced basis for the the
simulation so
this v star i is the best simulation
radius basis for simulation i
and the grassman distance is the angle
between
various radius bases between two reduced
bases
and therefore we obtain a matrix
of grass man distance between all the
simulation data
in this ambient space
that that look like a circle
and we thanks to this uh
matrix we can train
a camed with algorithm in order to
extract
meadowhead a meadowhead is a point
in the training set
that is close to the center of the
cluster
and so they are radius bases
but each radius basis being
a a training point
it is related to a specific input
parameter
mu k and thanks to this we get
a label data for um
temperature field for instance or for
images
and then we obtain a piecewise linear
approximation space like this
where the approximation space for
partial differential equations
is a subspace of a
finite element approximation space
but it uses a non-linear
model reduction because the radius basis
depends on the results of a classifier
that is where the the classifier takes
the input parameter mu in order
to recognize the best reduced basis
that we should use for this input
parameter
so we we obtain
a nonlinear reduction scheme through the
classifier
but we are using local
and linear projections of the finite
element equations
they are local in the cluster
and so uh the the classifier
is is solving the nonlinear aspect of
the
nonlinear model order reduction and we
still have a kind of transfer learning
thanks to the finite element residual
okay
so we can consider many target problems
involving image based modelling but not
only we know that the ambient space
for images is huge so
sensitive analysis sensitivity analysis
are not tractable to reduce the
parameter space
but convolutional neural networks
are very efficient in image
classification tasks
and it makes sense to adopt
cnn as a classifier in
romney
in addition fields in science
or finite element data can be
considered as images
this is a new parading to coupled
machine learning
and computational mechanics
in the sequel the temperature field
in a thermomechanical problem is
considered
as an input image of a romnet
so this is a numerical example in
a thermomechanical problem a stochastic
temperature field
is the input data for a mechanical
problem an elastoplastic problem
this problem is similar to the
computation of a tubing blade
it has the same constitutive equations
and each time we have a random
realization of the temperature field
we have to compute the mechanical
solution
of the elastoplastic problem
and we would like to use a romnet for
that
so the training steps of the romnet are
the following
first the parameter space is sampled
randomly and for each sample mu
i finite element simulation generates
simulation data
in order to compute the grassmann
distance between simulation data
the svd extracts the
ideal radius basis for each
simulation individually
next the full matrix of craftsman
distances
is computed between
all coppers of
ideal radius bases
the camedoid algorithm finds
the meadowheads in the grassmann
manifold
thanks to that we can label the
input thermal field according to the
results
of the clustering procedure based
on ideal radius basis
after that a cnn classifier
is trained to learn
the relation between the thermal field
and the labels
upon the results of the clustering
procedure
a local radius basis is trained
locally on each cluster
separately
so the clustering results are the
following
in this example radius bases have
two modes we can plot the grassman
manifold
by using a multi-dimensional scaling
of a scikit-learn and it is based on the
craftsman
distance mattress
on the left on uh so on the right
on the right we show
the results of the clustering procedure
based on the distance between
ideal radius bases
so we obtain a perfect
clustering by using six cluster
if we compare these results
with a clustering related
to the input temperature field
we can define six cluster
of input at your field by using
an equilibrium distance and we can see
that
there is no a straightforward relation
between the two clustering
procedure so
this is the reason why we need
a cnn classifier in order to
to learn the
the relation between input thermal field
parameter
and label labels of
cluster
okay on the top
right these curves show the density
probability function
for enter
dissimilarity by using the craftsman
distance
small dissimilarity means
low approximation errors
by using a nonlinear modal order
reduction
the red curve is the one obtained
by using only one cluster of data
it is uh the case when we want to train
a global reduced basis by
using linear model order reduction
so the red curve is the one obtained
without clustering
the blue curve is related to
the home net clustering based on
the grass man distance between ideal
radius bases
and we can see that we
reduce a lot the dissimilarity
inside each cluster of simulation data
and if we use six cluster
of temperature field it does not
improve anything inside
cluster of similar temperature field
so the right metric for the latent space
is given by the craftsman distance
between ideal radius basis ideal
local radius bases reduce basis
for each simulation
individually
so the cnn classifier is similar to the
one used in
alexnet here it has three blocks
of convolutional layers
and we use the relu activation function
and uh here we can see the results of
the
the the confusion matrix between the the
two
[Music]
labels and the the predicted levels
and the average accuracy is around
74 of accuracy
so it is quite good and this is
interesting to see
that uh um run
wrong wrong ladling
is not so a bad because
it gives a local radius basis
that is very close to the target to the
true
reduced basis and this can be
seen see here uh on this plot
here the these are these points are uh
points that should be in class zero
but the the the cnn says
that they are in class 1 but they are
not
so far from class 0.
so it is quite satisfactory to train
this cnn classifier
the we need as input thermal temperature
thermal input temperature input so uh
we we transform the definite element
data
into an image thanks to a regular mesh
and uh the the the the
in the thickness but we are using the
the channels
of the the 2d image to
to to set up the the training
data of the cnn
the final results are here uh the
the high fidelity model has 200
thousands of
degrees of freedom and
the the local radius bases are have only
two modes
uh for all clusters and there is six
clusters
and the simulation speed up is uh
60 and uh
the error in predicting plastic strain
by uh
this rom net uh is only uh
five percent so this accuracy is very
fine for
a certainty quantification
so there is several works in progress
in my team about rom nets
tom daniel is now working on a realistic
industrial cases for saffron
and uh hugo leone is developing auto
encoders
for a crack assessment in that work the
input parameters
are images of local cracks
and the pablo pereira is working on a
local radius basis for a real-time
prediction
of stress in a welding process
in that word the input parameter or
thermal field again
so my my conclusion is
new numerical methods are coupling
machine learning
and a solution of a partial differential
equation
and they are going to change the working
environment
for engineering and
data related to uh fields in uh
in mechanics can be a con considered
as tensor or images
and this is very interesting to develop
a image transformation
upon this id so
the step by step training of romnet
with intermediate classification results
facilitate the local interpretability
from that resource we can check if
the temperature input is similar to the
meadowhead
and we also can check if the mechanical
prediction
are similar to the metallic two and uh
the using grassmann matrix for the latin
metrics
is very interesting because it's quite
general approach
in computational mechanics and
eventually a cnn classifier
can handle non-parametric modeling
no knowledge on parameter are introduced
to solve the classification problem
and this is very interesting for a
non-parametric uncertainty
quantification
so thank you for your attention i
switched off my presentation
and if you want i can answer two
questions thank you thank you
david so much for the great talk um
um i really enjoyed it let's have a q a
session now
um okay so i don't see any questions in
the queue
the chat room but you you can unmute
yourself and then
uh ask ask questions um
okay so while you you are thinking about
the questions i have a question so yes
that's very uh you know you know
a good idea to um taking advantage of
the the cnn classifier
um you know to the cluster and
match that with a different label um
well what is the the speed up uh you're
getting
when you compare that to you know
corresponding to the model
and the speed up is the total speed up
is uh 60 compared to the finite element
solution in this uh simple case
okay the the thermal thermal mechanical
simulation yeah
okay yeah in fact we only have
a non-linear mechanical simulation
with a a thermal input
okay that's very nice okay the
simulation speed was
16. okay i missed that okay um there is
a question from
uh harshit um on slide 33
a probabilistic model for the input data
is needed why
is that the case so
yes
it's better because if we have a
probabilistic model
for a thermal field it's easier to
sample
the the input parameter space
so we can focus
data sampling thanks to this uh
probabilistic model
if not uh
it is uh maybe more more difficult but
it it is possible to sample
the the parameter space
anyway
good okay um thank you uh any other
questions from audience okay all right
crash
thank you okay rahul uh asked
um i'd like to know where the transfer
learning has been implemented for the
reduced
model yeah so uh it
it is a kind of learning it is
it is not the the same transfer learning
as
for cnn the transfer learning
here is related to the
residual of finite element equation in
that residual
we have all the mechanical knowledge
for instance about the constitutive
equation
about the loading and
about the geometry of the the
problem so since we are using
the finite element residual
we transfer this knowledge into
this non-linear scheme for modal order
reduction
yeah so um just added to that um
you know yeah it is a it's not a direct
application of the transfer learning in
machine learning
transfer learning for convolutional
neural network
yeah it's more more the analogy
another yeah direct application yeah
yeah we have knowledge and
we we don't want to train
neural network in order to uh
rediscover this knowledge
yeah yeah exactly wow just commented
that it's not a transfer of the weights
oh yeah the transfer of the price yeah
exactly
yeah okay um another question from me
is some technical details about the high
production
in on each local rom so
yeah so i'm assuming you are applying
the hyper reduction
each local rom so um when you apply that
you will
end up with a different set of the uh
you know the collocation uh yes
or yeah for different local rom right
so yeah you have to store that somewhere
in the system and then
once you know the cluster uh tells you
okay go to this cluster you
invoked those you know correct uh
hyper exact step so the classifier
gives the the cluster number and
uh for each cluster we have
a set of uh of data
related to hyper reduction we have the
radius basis
but also the the weight if you are using
uh
energy sampling approach and uh
we are so here we are using uh
uh the reduced domain so we have to uh
save the reduce mesh uh for each
cluster right right
okay so all right um bro
uh uh raul bravo has
another question given that you only
have six clusters and
that each of them returns two mode bases
was it necessary to use clustering
what is the gain compared to using a
single cluster and therefore a single
basis
okay um we did not use the ah
okay here is the comparison
[Music]
here so i i didn't
show all uh results
but the craftsman
distance is a kind of
upper bound for elastic problem is a
kind of
upper bound of the approximation
error when using reduced order modeling
so the the distance
inside uh each cluster the attra
distance
in in the same cluster are
much smaller by using six cluster than
by using only one cluster and
for each cases we are using a
radius basis of dimension two
it's hard to compare results by changing
the dimension of the radius basis
because
um
[Music]
but because it's it's more easier
to fix the dimension of the radius basis
and to compare
errors but we can
evaluate also we can evaluate the gain
in term of accuracy and
but for this gain we need to compare a
reduced basis
with the same number of
modes obviously
maybe for that problem we could
have used a reduced basis involving
maybe 100 mods
to account for the various effect
effects
of thermal fields but 100 mods
is a very huge basis and
i have to to mention that
computational complexity of reduced
order model
depends on the cube on the
the size of of the radius basis
to the power 3 because when you are
using
a local radius basis
we have to to to solve
linear problems that have full matrices
compared to finite element models that
have sparse matrices and empirically
we have to fulfill this
restriction and this means that
100 mods is very very high
for a reduced order model so this is the
reason why
sometimes we need to use clusters of
data
and rob nets to solve nonlinear
model order reduction yep
okay thank you and next question is by
uh beta is this method applicable for
odes as well
so sorry i was reading the previous uh
okay oh i'm i'm lost uh so
uh it's from beta the next question is
from
yeah it's uh is it applicable to
ordinary differential equation
yeah that's the question yes yes
[Music]
yes the the basis obtained
for a cluster is used
for all the simulation
if the classifier recognized
in the input image that we must use
the the cluster oh well okay so you you
just answer the rahu's question right
yes yes okay so thank you for that
okay let's go backwards okay uh
yeah it's a next next one is rather a
comment than question yeah
from rob blake uh he recommends to use
the k
sparse auto encoders and he also uh
you know made a link for for that uh
we'll see that later yeah thank you very
much
um interesting topic
exactly in order to obtain the
efficiency
yes okay the next question
is rahul's i'm going backward okay
although the temporal complexity is
reduced to what is the memory required
while solving for the reduced stone
order given that
it is a parametric resistor so the
the about the memory it depends on the
number of clusters
so uh it is if we have six cluster
it is uh six times more uh
memory demanding so uh
uh but um we just need
to uh um
the parameters for hyper reduction
and this parameter are
saved only for reduced mesh
if we need to save memory
we can use a kind of data printing
related to a hyper reduction
okay uh thank you and uh and answering
to beta's question
is method applicable to ordinary
differential equations
yeah i would say yes but i mean yes of
course
yes of course yes yeah yeah yeah
okay uh and another question from
rahul the speed up is 60 around 60. so
it still takes five days unlike
uh the finite element method simulation
which is of
of order of three hundred days
so where is the maximum computation okay
directly
so the the the the simulation that takes
300 days has 15 millions of degrees of
freedom
and the larger the fine the
high fidelity model the better the speed
up
so the speed up for this uh
we are where simulation finitely
simulate free time and simulation are
still running for that problem
and uh but the respect speed up
around 1 000 yeah
yeah so i mean usually if you just don't
know when it is applied to larger scale
problem
you will get a higher speed up so that's
yeah
the geometry is more complex but the
the mechanic the mechanics inside is not
so
complex yeah the intrins
intrinsic is still small yes
yeah okay um i i don't see any more
questions
from audience
yeah thanks so much okay um
thank you so much david for the
wonderful talk
and answering all those questions um
yeah and through this seminar talk i
hope that um
you know you will be connected with with
the many scientists
in lawrence livermore so that you can do
the collaboration
in the future yes that's one of the
motivation of this seminar talk so
so uh yeah
that i hope that it's going to happen
okay uh thank you so much
let's let's upload um great talk
for david thank you thank you so much
and
and uh and i'm i'm sorry i'll
change for the the rough start today uh
but worried i i guess we did we did
manage to to finish the uh the seminar
um you know without any hassle
um except the beginning part
okay thank you so much everyone yeah
thank you so much for everyone thank you
goodbye
okay we will see you uh in the next tdp
seminar
okay bye everyone